- [Voiceover] Measure
the angle in degrees.
So here we have this blue angle
that we want to measure in degrees,
and it's sitting on top of this circle.
That circle is actually a protractor.
Sometimes we see, and maybe
what you're used to seeing,
is protractors that are
more semicircle shaped,
something like this.
And those semicircle protractors measure
from zero to 180 degrees.
Which is good, but a
circle is even better.
A full circle is better because
an angle can measure up to 360 degrees.
So a full circle allows us to
measure and angle of any size,
instead of only an
angle up to 180 degrees.
Now the way we're gonna measure this angle
is the same way we would
on a semicircle protractor.
The first thing we wanna do is
make sure one of our
rays lines up to zero.
So here's one of our rays,
and it's lining up to
zero on the protractor.
So that's nice, it's
already lined up for us.
And then we're gonna measure the opening
all the way to the other
ray, to right here.
And so if our angle only
measured opened up this far,
it would be a 10 degree angle.
If let's say it opened to here,
it would be a 50 degree angle.
But our angle measures
all the way to here,
to the 160 degrees.
So 160 degrees is the
measure of our angle.
And again, when you measure
on a circle protractor,
or any protractor for that matter,
you're gonna line one ray up to the zero,
and then measure the opening
'til you get to the other ray,
which in this case
opened up to 160 degrees.